pas de nouvel exploit après la victoire
face à Henet pour les joueuses de
Montini en Coupe de France devant
Octeville sur mer pensionnaire de
Division 2 les inimontain en vert n'ont
rien pu faire face au grand gabarit des
arrières Octevillais malgré une défense
très dure et des montées de balles
rapides l'écart se creuse vite 17 à 9 à
la pause pour Octeville offensivement il
était difficile de trouver les solutions
défensivement c'est c'est beaucoup plus
d'effort qu'à l'accoutumé les gabarits
sont différents là on avait trois filles
qui nous mettaient largement en tête
donc c'est difficile d'y faire face
grâce à un excellent début de seconde
période les joueuses de Stéphane paysan
font une partie de leur retard et ne
sont plus menés que de 5 buts avant de
louper quelques opportunités de tir et
de craquer physiquement en fin de
rencontre 3419 à l'arrivée le score est
peu flatteur mais l'entraîneur
inimontain reste fier de ses files on
essayer de faire ce qu'on sait faire
c'estd que défendre assez dur démonter
les ballons prise de risque alors il y a
beaucoup de perdes de balle mais c'est
c'est notre jeu on a beaucoup de prise
de risque dans notre jeu c'est le jeu
que je demande donc les filles ont fait
ce qu'il fallait faire voilà 15 c'est
pas est ridicu les inones peuvent
désormais se concentrer uniquement sur
le championnat de National 2 à commencé
par ce samedi avec la réception du S
avenis en
B